there's a very interesting development
which is that Donald Trump has a serious
primary challenger now let me sort of
explain what I mean by serious by
serious I don't mean someone that has
any chance of actually beating Donald
Trump in the Republican primary but it's
serious in that it's someone who is more
of an actual Republican as far as the
perception of him than William weld
who's running against Trump and his name
is Joe wolf
he's a former congressman Joe Walsh told
George Stephanopoulos on his ABC Sunday
morning show yesterday that he is
running for president in the Republican
primary against Donald Trump president
points too often is just about every
poll shows more than 80 percent support
for the president among Republicans they
don't have an alternative I'll tell you
what George and look I'm running because
he's unfit somebody needs to step up and
there needs to be an alternative the
country is sick of this guy's tantrum
he's he's a child again the litany he
lies every time he opens his mouth now
everything is working against this guy
okay Trump has a very high approval
rating among Republicans but not as high
as Trump thinks Trump says it's a 95
percent approval rating it's more like
80 according to a new Associated Press
poll Walsh has a lot of exploitable
personal issues including allegedly
being a deadbeat dad the Republican
National Committee isn't going to
support a primary challenge to Donald
Trump but and this is the dream joe
walsh might be able to get in the way
just enough to become an annoyance to
donald trump which would be really great
trump has a high approval rating among
Republicans but it's not set in stone
many Republicans say they support Trump
merely because they don't like Democrats
and it's their way of showing it but
there is 21% of Republicans that already
does not support Donald Trump and that
is a fifth of the party that might be
interested in an alternative Republican
to Donald Trump the RNC won't support a
primary challenge but they don't even
really need to because the goal here is
not to beat Trump in the primary in the
same way that the goal of an impeachment
inquiry isn't to remove Trump before
2020 the goal of all of these ideas is
to weaken Donald Trump
so do we on the left want people running
against Trump from within the Republican
Party absolutely
the stronger they are the happier we are
to see it Democrats can just keep
running their primary and meanwhile
anything that could weaken Donald Trump
is a good thing
walsh running against Trump might lead
to some money being spent that otherwise
wouldn't an impeachment inquiry would
replace some Trump campaign media
stories with some impeachment inquiry
stories and that could damage Donald
Trump remember 2016 was decided by
70,000 votes in three states any of
these things that could weaken Donald
Trump or interfere with Donald Trump
being able to set the narrative we
should welcome and we should encourage
this is Donald Trump strength when he
sets the narrative and gets the media in
a frenzy gets them spending three five
or seven days on something that Trump
benefits from or at least that Trump
would prefer they focus on other than
some more damaging thing that is good
for Donald Trump joe walsh is a
disgusting ideological clown he's
completely unqualified to be President
of the United States but Republicans
already voted in a guy who's completely
unqualified to be President by all means
have at it Joe see what you can do see
what amount of support he can pick off
from the Republican Party and by the way
don't forget and this is like the dream
scenario if Joe Walsh can get some
traction with the fifth of the
Republican Party that doesn't approve of
Trump again latest poll from The
Associated Press 79 percent of
Republicans approve of Trump 21 percent
don't okay that's one fifth of
Republicans if Joe Walsh can pick up
three percent support five percent
support in the Republican primary
obviously he loses the primary that may
be enough it may give him enough money
and may give him enough momentum to say
you know what I'm gonna run as a third
party because Joe Walsh has said he's a
terrible guy but he said he apologizes
for his role in helping to elect Trump
in 2016 if his goal is really to do
anything he
and to remove Trump he might say I'm in
a run third party and there when you
look at how close it was in so many key
states Wisconsin Michigan other states
Joe Walsh running as a Republican could
actually I'm sorry Joe Walsh running as
an independent could actually take
enough Republican votes away from Donald
Trump that it flips one state to the
eventual Democratic nominee two states
to the eventual Democratic nominee so
this is not strategy for the left what
we need to do is run a fair primary and
then get people to vote get people to
vote who otherwise wouldn't half the
country doesn't vote find people who
already agree with us tell them this was
a very small margin in this state in
that state in whichever state you should
vote that's still our strategy but if
Joe Walsh is going to create an annoying
distraction like a mosquito that you
just can't get to get leave you alone
for Donald Trump
up until the Republican National
Convention and then might actually run
as an independent he could
single-handedly hand a state or two to
the Democratic nominee and conceivably
turn this election it might not happen
we should support it because it does
nothing bad for us and potentially does
some good things yeah it's it's an
obvious dead end
in what it is in that Trump is going to
be the Republican nominee unless he were
to drop out or something who knows but
it is not a dead end in that it could
have a real impact and really hurt
Donald Trump in the eventual general
election if you disagree with me tell me
where I'm wrong on the numbers okay if
you disagree with me for some other
reason I guess also let me know but the
real case I'm making is that
mathematically this could have an impact
that is not good for Donald Trump